so you sent you sent me this merch the
line of Saudi Arabia city of a future
yeah I don't even really have time I do
this but if you scroll through and I
just show like when they're explaining
the diagram and how some of this stuff
works so they're building
like a dystopian indoor Matrix City
like in Saudi Arabia that's going to be
like a gajillion miles long and it looks
like a giant pane of glass from the
outside like it literally just looks
like a giant freestanding mirror and
they're gonna [__] stick people in
these God they want everyone to live
it's you don't really talk like the 15
minutes or whatever yeah yeah this is
everything all rolled into one place
question because it's not just a formal
one so we came to us with a team of
Engineers trying to ask ourselves tough
questions I guess what I love about Dion
it's it's at the Nexus of new
technologies Innovations Urban
revolutions let's think about
buzzwords buzzwords what is this new
communities how they're going to be
using Urban space part of the the walk
the line that you're going to live in
this is a new way Knox so what are the
renderings and visualizations of the
line tell us about today's ideals for
the future we thought that that this
would generate a sort of uh integration
of community and they say if you scroll
to when the little scary looking
gray-haired Eric push off Asian guy is
talking to the people that's when it
gets you go uh I think he was up ahead a
little bit more more this is no in
between like where you were like it's
like a third of the way through you'll
see this little guy in a black outfit
like a little he's dressed like [__]
Tim Cook or whatever or what's this
what's the guy uh that he stole it from
the Apple guy there's a little [__] a
new way of living uh jab guy I think
it's coming up right here these big
projects is that they need everything to
come together you have to have the
Architects you have to have the money
the top down power it's kind of this
Alchemy almost yeah this guy
I know I didn't know it was this long
dude my bad
uh I'll find it I'll find it
he's Asian you said it's kind of asiany
looking he's very short little guy with
like gray Eric Bischoff hair
[__] how long this
this is around that part
up again it's gonna take me away the
walking distance
that's what we want to happen in the
line
170 kilometers long there will be 140
modules each one 200 meters wide and 800
meters long you know this remind you
ever play that game fallout shelter
yes yeah this is basically yeah bro it's
Sim Tower yeah but it's also like that
but it's above ground it's like a human
ant farm
but also standing 500 meters above sea
level each module will be able to
accommodate 80 000 people everybody was
playing Fallout Shelter while they were
watching equilibrium 500 meters 80
000 people I'm just gonna smoke in here
because I do it anyway I just I don't
even want to take a break I want a break
this is [__] so creepy in dystopia
and the Finish Line will have a capacity
to house a population of 9 million
it is fundamentally in an ant farm
did he and a vertical City that's
structured this way
is a completely new thing the line
promises to innovate Rove this is gross
see I just I was panicking when we
couldn't find a good time stamp but I'm
like God I don't want to blow this
because this is a great [__] thing to
cover it's so [__] creepy
holy [__]
I love when the smart people go this has
never been done the line in South it's
like we've been on this planet for
thousands of years at this point if it
hasn't been done or tried before it's
probably because it doesn't work yeah no
no yeah and you know what the and I know
you're saying that just to like you know
kind of go fine let's assume you're
right but we all know it has been done
before maybe not with this level of
Technology but the idea of a mega city
has been done before and it never ends
well
every aspect of City living but for most
of its life since it's Genesis in 2017
the development of the idea has been
undertaken in the strictest secrecy the
fact that that's why we like secrecy too
that it was secret is of course curious
in relation to how big it is
I mean it's pretty hard to miss we spent
a lot of time understanding
relationships and architecture but in
this case relationships and architecture
you know what you didn't spend any time
doing studying the human psyche studying
humans and under developing a human
psyche yeah you have they really know
for real that these [__] these
[__] Architects are retards like they
really really are you guys only think
about post-modern architectures [__]
dystopian garbage and this is like the
Pinnacle of dystopian garbage now where
you're going to build Mega City [__]
one but not even that because Mega City
one at least was wide you're gonna put
Mega City one in a straight line into
the sky and be like no you know what
humans want to live like this they want
to live they want to have nine million
people going up and down like I'm living
on [__] Deep Space Nine
by far the first time terrifying [__]
gross is [__] gross I've ever heard
and thought about something else
gross this is like
it's like when talking about well let's
have we thought about curvature of the
Earth the word is yeah I know
this is working the whole architectural
world is a sort of net look at this this
is gonna put nine million people in a
goddamn glass box you want me to listen
to this guy who really who says things
like now the Nerds are trying to stick
us in a locker you want me to listen to
this guy who says things like actually
Garfunkel is more talented [__] off I'm
not gonna listen to this [__] this
guy could suck my dick with his vest
where I have fairly close personal
friends camera Krista caught Ian Malcolm
yeah but you were so busy wondering if
you could you didn't stop to think if
you should and this time who eventually
it emerges that they're doing something
to do with nail and you're all very sort
of cagey about it oh yeah this guy oh
yeah okay you know what um
this was the [__] all right never
mind I'm gonna drop another link but
keep playing this this is great I'll be
I don't know what you're saying but this
already is amazing but this guy looks
like the bad guy from Demolition Man I
found it do you realize oh no no no no I
you know what I sent the full doc that I
was watching last night like an idiot
um no this is uh the one I just dropped
this was the propaganda piece that's
creepy this is what I meant to [__]
because I'm showing you the full doc but
yeah where did you put it just popped in
the in the the prep Frozen thing that is
the [__] that's the one with the
creepy little Bishop guy
[Music]
because we can Implement Global best
practice into every element of the city
we'll be working with the best
Architects and planners from around the
world in order to take all of the
learnings we've inherited from other
cities and create a new city from
scratch at the line and an earthquake
killed 9 million people
[Laughter]
an urban model which provides
unprecedented livability a model for
nature preservation and sustainability
man you guys really think you're gonna
stop God when he comes huh that's
adorable
that's adorable and unique environment
this feels like a commercial you would
see in the an episode of dark mirror you
know what I mean or a commercial you
would see in Robocop yes economic growth
I am tari kadumi and I am the executive
yeah this would be the luxury place to
live in like a Robocop future exactly
yeah like if you're rich come live at
the law at the line protect it germs and
Outsiders and outliers
what if you wanted to live in the
perfect City hi I'm a guy with the name
of every bad guy from every 90s actor me
hi I'm every bad guy from the movies you
grew up watching I think hi I'm the smug
guy from Gremlins too yeah
and I'd like to tell you about the line
you know what no no no no no no clamp
did nothing wrong he saved them at the
end so do not don't you ever go after
clamp Industries my friend not on my
watch okay
hey Bessie who is the actor that was
like best friends with Nicholson and he
was in like everything Nicholson was in
but he was like oh Peter Fonda he played
the rapist in a uh Sling Blade [__]
in today's news the mattress fire killed
235 000 lives in a quadrant 254 of line
City 13. oh my God that's [__]
hilarious just the giant building from
cyberpunk hi I'm Charles Pendleton and I
am the executive director for the line
proponent oh God
and I'm a senior architect at neum urban
planning bro
urban planning is [__] architecture
architect has become this people that
used to look you know what architecture
used to be Marsh remember what
architecture used to be it used to be
like let's build something that's
functional but looks pretty but mostly
let's make sure that everyone's happy if
you've got a little long lasting long
lasting functional let's make it pretty
let's do that and now architecture's
like I'm an artist
it has gotten bad [__] crazy and it's
unfortunate because urban planning
should have like just like the medical
field and every other form of science it
should have practical like [__]
applications and it would correct but
they don't they either just want they
either want you to live an absolute
squalor and asbestos yeah and like live
like Chinese conditions or you live in
the mega [__] you know you live in
that [__] giant Tower in Dubai and
like even then every every time your
heart rate goes up a little bit too much
they like page your room and go like are
you working out or are you okay and
you're like I'm fine
thanks
[Music]
annual Biometrics at every moment that's
great I don't want to know I don't need
you to know when I'm jerking off are
they actually building this
um
my name is Michio Kaku oh god I didn't
even
see him last night I was skipping
through so much
oh no
I didn't even know it was him it's
[__] Neil deGrasse Tyson a smug
another smug
is like donut with sprinkles yeah yeah
yeah
[__] him [__] him oh no I didn't know I
did not know I was stumbling on a Michio
Cocker is he like a shingy he is he used
to go on Opie and Anthony all the time
right he was like pre-nailed just grass
Tyson right and this guy's like some
space science guy whatever theoretical
physicist he [__] like a physics dude
whatever and like he would go on Ona and
he would explain science like people
were absolute retards like they were
four
you'd be like you see time is like
vanilla ice cream and then the movement
of the movement objects in universe is
like hot fudge I hate this guy Jimmy
Jimmy Jimmy Norton used to actually do a
really good bit ripping on this [__]
guy yeah back when he sled fangs I'm a
professor of theoretical physics and I'm
also a futurist what will a city of the
future look like when I was a child I
used to think about the city of the
future are we gonna have flying cars are
we going to visit the moon and Mars what
a dork no we never did any of those
things
began to look at these cities like Paris
we're losing in Ukraine now got that
going for us yay London New York and I
saw traffic jams I saw by the way some
of these guys actually know him I'd say
triple n he's still peddling his
[__] String Theory Colonius in the
chat string theory is
it is
[Laughter]
I love you guys I hate this guy
and I saw tremendous inequalities and I
said to myself we can do better we can
stop everyone into this one Locker like
they used to do to me when I was a kid I
want everyone to feel what I felt like
in high school that's all it is yeah
you're right
they're compressing the whole world into
a cube and they're like isn't that great
no it's a [__] board
you will be assimilated they were the
[__] bad guys remember
except for Hugh the good remember the
good one the good one Hugh and we were
[__] happy when we got Picard back I
thought are we like [__] did we
change as a society
Picard does a time traveling episode
gets to the line and goes what have we
done have the board gone back in time
and taken over again
number one take me into the other
quadrant I'm joining the Klingon
sustainable livable a city of the future
the lines Dosher can I read this one
this is a great search out on Rumble for
five I hate these futurist engineers and
scientists they saw the same dystopian
movies we saw growing up but they didn't
understand the point was not to do it
road map so perfect yeah
it shows us a new yeah yeah yes Forest
mommy they're really building it
you know what the line reminds me of
y'all remember back in the day when [__]
it Dubai tried to build those like
Island City things yeah oh yeah the
little they're still trying to do it and
they're still a mess
yeah and [__] only one of them worked
and two of them are sinking back into
the ocean yep and they wanted to build
skyscrapers on them
on Sand yeah
that was dredged
this great idea guys two way of doing
things a new pattern by which we could
make a livable future
Jack's Jack Stark equilibrium is not an
instruction manual [__] it's for real
nice making to me is about creating the
canvas for Community it's about creating
spaces for people to want to visit and
live in a place that cares for its
Society yeah where's the industrial
[__] the industrial part of your city
where's the manufacturing it sounds like
a bunch of commie gobbledygook if you
ask me
guys they care about us yeah look at
that look they're walking in the
straight line
and you know Virgie you're missing the
point there this is late stage City
skylines where you can get rid of most
your industry yeah yeah and the guy in
the back is yeah these keep these people
really care about the Common Man the guy
in the back is wearing a pair of 800
Crown Northampton shoes no you're right
they care about you yeah nice creation
of the [__] Beatles cover album you
[__] mm-hmm
except yoko's already in this one in the
front yeah
many demographers think that the cities
of the future will contain about 50
million people that's not livable at all
that's a lot they don't have to yeah we
are working on creating a you can't
leave the line
by which we can create cities
that looks like if dude if I showed you
a diagram of that happening to your car
you go no please don't crush my car into
a cube hey Marsh hey Marsh why don't we
play a little bit of the real civil
engineer building it we have to right I
haven't yeah we have oh God yes okay let
me let's explain can I point can I can I
give a little backstory here sure go
ahead so Royce got me turned out he knew
I was playing City skylines again so
Royce was like yo check out real civil
engineer he's [__] he's actually he's
a real civil engineer but he plays City
skylines and he's a [__] maniac and
he's hilarious and he does really good
like commentary well and he just does
these insane experiments with like
sewage and poop and it's really good
mountains and like he just didn't say he
you can tell this man he's the Joseph
mangle of like engineering science but
he just is like I just play City
skylines and see what what can you do so
I didn't even know about the line I've
been just watching this guy as I'm
looking up City skylines videos last
night and then he was pup like I thought
he was just being a weirdo and then he's
like no this is a real thing and he
interspersed like a couple clips and I
was like
whoa what is this I tried to bring the
real line of the show but yeah this is
how I even figured out the line was an
actual thing in the world oh the Arabia
you may have heard about the Seattle
engineering project a city for nine
million residents crammed into a 500
meter tool 200 meter wide line structure
that's 170 kilometers long and if you
believe the marketing's built it'll look
lovely everything is automated and it
has zero carbon emissions I imagine
there's a huge once built disclaimer
somewhere there though costing just a
measly three trillion dollars you'll be
with a measly three trillion dollars
five minute walk to everything you could
possibly need oh and did I mention it's
housed entirely in glass in the desert
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
who comes up with this stuff designed by
World leading Architects oh yeah yeah
absolutely I see The Architects because
he's an engineer
that's [__] great he hates architects
of this channel
yeah that's good that's good that's good
this is what happens when a country with
a lot of money has Architects that can
create crazy Concepts and they vomit out
a load of buzzwords spend Millions on
crazy marketing videos get everyone
hyped up and then an engineer is brought
in once all the budget has been spent
and told make it work mate anyway
[Laughter]
hello fellow engineers and welcome to
City skylines now where today I'm going
to be starting a new game and we're
going to be creating the line I've
downloaded a map from the Steam Workshop
called The Long deserted desert yes that
sounds like a nice place to start so
I've just bought the entire map I mean I
am an oil Baron now so I can afford to
do whatever I want basically
as an oil Baron while he's doing it oh
yeah because he has to use all the
unlocks or he'll never get it done so he
just yeah he's all the cheats and mods
on it makes sense
that's kind of what it's like right if
you're [__] a Saudi Prince
episode
anything like that however surely there
are actually going to be roads to get to
it otherwise how is anyone gonna get
there so I think we definitely need to
start this Junction and maybe I can go
underground so people can't really see
but yeah 170 kilometers long that's
that's quite far I mean each one of
these squares is one kilometer by one
kilometer so it
70 of these squares in a row I think our
line might be a little bit different but
it should give us a good idea of how the
thing could look could work I don't know
let's see what happens now obviously
because it's in the desert and because
it's coated in glass there is going to
be some heat stuff going on all right so
I reckon that will be weird
because we've got to get from one end to
the other in just 20 minutes actually
bloody how how fast would that be 170
kilometers and 20 minutes I assuming the
matters right 510 kilometers an hour
which is
317 miles an hour what the hell sort of
traveling Contraption are they using I I
love it because even forget the skyline
stuff that he's building since he's a
civil engineer he's pointing out this
stupid promo video these all these great
ideas it's like okay but functionally
you cannot how do you make this work
functionally and that's have equipment
it's capable of this correct it's like
this [__] and then
when he started building it
in this thing well I'm pretty sure our
monorail will still be able to compete
so let's get a Monorail station involved
there we go Monorail station so now we
have monorails that hopefully can travel
300 here we go we go the line is
literally coming together
oh it's actually I'm quite surprised
that people are actually moving in for
some reason
is absolutely fuming so he made the
bottom industrial yes well there answers
your question Virgie there you go Virgie
there it is
everywhere it's going good oh God how
funny would it be if they actually put
Factories at the bottom of the line
wow this is quite a sight so I think
what's going on with the trees the trees
having a disco the trees will go mental
I don't know what they're dancing to
it's definitely not my million sub
special that was horrible
but yeah I think I'm gonna continue
growing this in that direction and then
we're gonna see oh look we've already
got we've already got water down here
okay so the question is can I build my
dam now this is this is like it's it
here one more thing oh and this is his
specialty the food is that's not
supposed to happen anyway fire engines
are oh no there's a fire what happens
because the monorail is on top and that
was always my plan to the untrained eye
it looks like it looks like there's no
cars in this city right right fire
appears to be an issue
which by the way
fire is gonna is gonna be a real issue
here that's where jobs are that's well
remember somebody in the chat earlier
said a mattress fire killed 22 000.
exactly and so Place making to me is
about creating a legacy creating a
template by which other nations can then
compare their cities their plans with
what's being done here in Saudia oh so
like globalism yes okay this is a
clarify
yeah maybe don't talk about globalism in
your hanging plant city you know what I
mean yeah [__] it seriously
Upper Valley it starts out at 500 meters
height and then slowly as the topography
Rises it disappears into the mountains
this is where we're starting
construction we bring in a canal from
the river oh well don't worry the pilots
you just
go wait a minute hey what's this plane
coming at me oh God that's me an entire
side of the line is just dead birds
oh God that's right the birds
you're trying to live in the line and
all you hear is food
s I'm so glad I brought that to the show
no no no I'm playing a little bit more
perfect I'm not moving I'm not moving on
yeah I ain't moving on now I'm obsessed
with this mine is I know it's a [__]
it's insane yeah here you go let's let's
go ahead and keep playing it hold on we
produce energies through solar wind and
hydrogen we also have 100 sustainable
water meaning we take out water through
desalination from the sea however by the
way this is Zion in Matrix it's on the
screen
this is a matrix
watch watch with the audio it works
watch
[Music]
is where the mobility at height is going
to be happening
and what are the shops where people can
go shopping for all of here is shops
right so
it means that to be office spaces
to the other after the other you get the
line absolutely
this is great
you know kilonia says a great Point
notice not a single masculine white man
is involved of course not
no of course time yes so it's never
getting done yeah so the sniper is never
gonna get finished
I sent you an update on it
what's here
it's it's actually just them uh trying
to get more people to throw money at
this [__] stupid idea
[Music]
they're doing it on purpose right
welcome to looking for this is where all
the today we're going back to a subject
this is literally the background music
from when they burned Arbiter yeah oh my
God it is it's Halo 2. bro bro I swear
to God and I'm on my life that's what I
was typing this Halo 2 theme on my life
because that's honestly what it reminded
me of and I was like what does it remind
me of I listen I have to I think it is
they think they just stole the music
okay you know what I'm meeting this and
playing the Halo music let's just see
this also absolutely works
[Music]
Halo so Westworld
wait I also have to live in the Middle
East no
oh [__] working actually
[Music]
oh this is great this looks like a
proper promo for Sid Meier's Alpha
Centauri yeah
it's Halo
[Music]
this Starfield promo sucks I know
seriously
it disappeared yeah I can't see anything
oh I lost it hold on there it goes
[Music]
you know it's so dumb man they can't
just take like some of these Concepts
and they can work on a practical level
no
you know like they have some good ideas
like I'm all for the uh the the the
coloring buildings a certain way to like
lower the temperature and like you know
I'm all for putting some vegetation on
buildings and [__] that's what I'm fine
and good but like
they're they're just like we're gonna
put everybody in a a press
what a crush you like a car crash [__] I
feel playing Halo too now God damn what
a good game that was
um
four player Halo Two
Bros
of 840 000 square meters half the size
of Monaco
as you can I cannot believe they're
doing this from the promotional I
realize that's just footage of [__]
Dallas's new stadium I was yep the
retractable Dome I do everything seems
to have been designed to accommodate
wealthy visitors there will be a marina
with just 86 perths so you can bring
your Yachts to the island
on the island on Liberty luxury hotels
will be built
Driftwood Promenade Yacht Club Golf
Course private beaches life on siddler
is like a private [__] word the core
is Too Well
by 2028 a figure that pales in
comparison with Dominion we don't have
any of these floating cars bro I was
gonna say we oh sorry so we're also
going to ask the civil engineers to
develop hover cars
it's just you know what I mean hover car
technology why are we building this
already
okay look if the Saudis are [__]
literally like wasting billions on it
trillions that why not let them
you know what some of that money back
let's get a couple of Union contractors
in there though
uh
uh here hold on uh you know what you
know what it is what was that movie it
was uh
was it player one was that the name of
that of that movie
or oh Ready Player One Ready Player okay
you're okay ready the one where he lives
in like vrs yeah yeah okay but the
reason the reason I'm saying that is
because that's what they're gonna that's
what they're gonna say they're gonna
give you and here's what you're actually
gonna get
this is what the city's really going to
look like here I've actually showed in
this scene right here
there it is that's the city a bunch of
trailer parks stacked on top of each
other
I told Brazil so everything's gonna look
like Brazil it'll look like diamond City
in Fallout 4.
it's like they looked at fabulous and
said what if we made that but with like
without the sheet metal what if the
world was a favela
um yeah this is this is
okay we're gonna move on but honestly I
would literally could talk about this
the entire show because this really made
me angry like I'm gonna I'm gonna watch
more of it now after this is [__]
wild I was definitely gonna do a little
this time I was gonna maybe do it on
nightwave we did so much of it on here
but now that it's in there I'm like oh I
got it it's so but you have a few 45
minutes of video immersed you could do
plenty of it trust me